hopefully I'm in the right room and you
all are in the right room and if we're
not the other speaker will come and kick
me out soon and that'll be a fun
adventure but this is improving pie
spark performance or spark be on the JVM
as i like to think about it since we now
have the spark are and sparkly are
people hanging out in very similar
interfaces and performance
considerations what my examples are
going to be in python because i don't
know our shits hard um so I'm holdin my
preferred pronouns are she or her it's
tattooed on my wrists if you ever forget
I'm a principal software engineer at IBM
spark Technology Center in San Francisco
I would do a recruiting pitch now if I
was in the Bay Area but if any of you do
want to come work on spark please find
me and I've been working on sort of
related problems for a while at a bunch
of different companies and I'm a
co-author of the learning spark book I
gave away my last learning spark sticker
but you can go and buy that book and
several other books you can follow me on
Twitter for pictures of cats pictures of
my good friend boo and one of my new
stuffy friends and occasionally stuff
about programming but mostly not and I
forgot a SlideShare with the slides from
this talk and most of my other talks so
I'm going to start with sort of what my
assumptions are about y'all as an
audience and hopefully I'm not too far
off base but if I am I can go and grab
another presentation and we can change
it up we're going to start with a quick
background over how high spark works
just because it's kind of important to
understand the internals just a little
bit so we can get some cool performance
and then we'll start talking about how
to reuse distributed data and spark will
talk about a bunch of considerations for
working with key value data and then
we're going to do sort of detour into
the happy land of sparks equal and data
frames and yeah we'll also look at some
tricks that you can use to intermix jvm
code with your Python code for the few
times that you give up and are you know
are converted to the dark side we have
cookies they're pretty delicious
or we can just think of this is this
talk is going to help your spark
programs go from this kind of pissed off
cat that's going to claw your eyes out
to this really happy unicorn that
totally isn't going to run out of memory
so I'm hoping you're all nice people
it's a PI data conference I haven't run
into mean people out of PI data
conference yet if you are please leave
if you object to pictures of cats I'm
sorry you're gonna have to ignore the
top right-hand corner of most of my
slides I'm hoping y'all might know some
Apache spark but I'm assuming that might
not be true for everyone could I see a
show of hands for people who have never
used spark before ok cool that's that's
pretty legit and the rest of you have
some spark experience or just don't want
to raise your hands either way it's ok I
get it it's fine so we're going to do
some like really basic intro we stuff
just bar but then we're going to focus
more on performance and for the people
who haven't ever used spark before the
performance focus might be a little bit
like what are we talking about but you
can follow it up later if you're like
excited about this and the parts will
hopefully you finally click well I mean
that's the theory I don't know whatever
so what is spark spark is a
general-purpose distributed computing
system it has some limitations but we
can do sort of arbitrary computations on
top of it it has to sort of core
abstractions for distributed data and
distributed operations there's resilient
distributed data sets or rd deeds and
then there's also data frames or data
sets and i'll use those two words
interchangeably because on the scale
aside the types are now equal for the
most part but in the python side that
they're not for reasons that really
don't matter but we can think of it as
having this sort of distributed
collection mechanism for us which
automatically distributes both the data
and the work across our cluster it's a
lot of people find spark because they're
coming from a MapReduce background and
they're like why is my MapReduce job so
slow this is terrible and then they're
like oh hi cool there's this thing
called spark and it says it's a hundred
times faster and then they try it and
they're like well hundred maybe not
quite but like 50 is pretty good
and then you know we've sucked you into
our web oh sorry I'm very serious
business yeah and and so one of the
really cool things about spark compared
to other parts of the Hadoop ecosystem
and this does have some downsides I'm
supposed to stand next to the mic sorry
so there's this sort of core apache
spark layer one on top of it there's all
of these other components and these
components all ship together so if you
want to use a sequel engine to do some
data cleaning and then do some machine
learning on top of it you don't have to
go and get two separate projects and get
them both deployed into production you
can just do that all inside of spark
which is kind of cool right because you
know none of us really do machine
learning on its own we always have to do
some data prep unless you like have six
junior analysts locked up in your
basement in which case please share I
don't want to do data cleaning anymore
there's also streaming so if you have
like streaming data coming in you can
you can also process that in spark and
what's really cool is that you can use
sort of the same tools that you use for
batch processing and spark to do the
streaming processing in spark so you can
actually just take some of your code and
switch it into a streaming mode and you
don't have to rewrite a whole bunch of
stuff it's kind of cool or vice versa
you know if it's got like a stream
processing thing and then occasionally
it turns out that you want to do a
backfill you can take your stream
processing code and just switch it to
run on top of our dd's you can do your
back fill their so it's pretty cool
there's graph tools they don't really
work very well so don't use them there's
an external community package for graph
tools it doesn't ship together but you
can use it as part of the integrated
environment you just have to tell spark
you want to use it together you can just
do that with a whole bunch of things so
the first thing that we're going to sort
of have to wrap our head around is this
thing called the spark context and we
can think of it as our window to the
giant world of spark and distributed
computing so it can be used to create
distributed collections so load the data
from HDFS or from a local file system or
from a local collection and turn it into
a distributed collection that we can do
sort of arbitrary work on a we can also
use it to
create sort of weird things called
counters and accumulators we're not
going to touch on them too much because
they don't work very well but the nice
thing is if you're using spark and you
just go and download it there's there's
a built-in shell environment and the
shell environment will automatically
create a spark context for you so you
don't have to figure out all that much
about it you just you just know that you
use the spark context and your spark
contacts can be pointed at like a local
cluster for testing and this just runs
like a fake cluster on your laptop which
honestly is how I do a lot of my like
development and prototyping is just like
does this work on my laptop because I
travel way too much and i'm not on
corporate Wi-Fi very often but then you
can just take your same job and you can
just repoint it at your cluster and you
know you can run your notebook against
the cluster and everything is going to
be awesome and happy cool and and so r
dds are the thing that we get when we
ask the spark contacts to load some data
for us and our dd's are distributed
collections and they're done a bit
differently than other distributed
collections have traditionally been done
in the past so with MapReduce the method
of achieving resiliency for for failure
in our cluster was to write the data out
to a whole bunch of different machines
and in spark the idea is if something
goes wrong that's okay I'll just
recompute that little missing piece of
data and what's really cool is we don't
have to like tell it how to recompute
this missing piece of data because it
uses lazy evaluation as we construct an
RDD it's actually constructing this
little secret hidden graph behind you
know the the metrical curtain where the
person lives and this this magical graph
tells spark how to recompute the data if
anything's missing and so if something
goes wrong it just goes back to its
graph and says okay okay I'm missing
part see how do i compute part c and it
does that for us and this this is one of
the things that leads to spark to be
faster than MapReduce or our systems
like it because writing out to three
disks over our network is kind of slow
compared to just like keeping a pointer
around in case something goes wrong and
yeah it's awesome the lazy evaluation
will probably trip you up at some point
in the future so so one of this
the downsides of the sort of model is
that I can do a whole bunch of
computation or it can look like I've
done a whole bunch of computation but
until I actually asked spark to save the
results somewhere it's not actually
going to do that computation and like I
could have actually tried to load a file
which doesn't exist and I won't get an
error message until I try and save my
results that have to like main memory
right and so that's that can be
confusing because you're like my error
messages aren't related to anything
that's going on near here and this can
be frustrating but I think it's worth it
because it makes our code super fast
compared to MapReduce so that's cool for
the people that we're already using pi
spark or just afraid of putting up their
hands there's some interesting changes
in spark 20 the bridge between the
Python and the JVM layer is getting
faster yay not a lot faster but faster
if you've been using this thing called
the sequel context or hive context
you're going to want to switch that to
the spark session the API is pretty
similar but you have to construct it
differently and this is just unifying
this because it didn't really make sense
to have these two separate contacts that
were both pretty much doing the same
thing data frames have gotten a lot
faster which is really awesome whoo and
part of that is we have better filter
push downs and sparks equal and this is
really cool so if we're loading some
data and then we selects a few columns
out of it and then we go and do some
operations on it and maybe we filter it
down to a subset spark will look and see
if our data source might be able to
perform some of that filtering for us in
advance right so if we're Lee if we're
reading from partitioned parque data
it'll be like Oh awesome I just only
need to read this small subset of my
data and the fastest data to process is
data that I never load right so that's
that's pretty cool and it's really
convenient um we could have always been
filter push down ourselves right but
then we have to think about it and
that's not something I remember doing
pretty lazy so i think this is cool as
data frames we can now have streaming
data frames and you can think of it as
like a streaming sequel table it doesn't
really work yet please don't use it with
the API is there and you
sort of play with it but don't use it in
production they'll have a bad time and
yeah cool oh yeah and I work for IBM so
i'm going to show you this really nice
graph where it strongly implies IBM is
awesome and I think we're awesome but
obviously I'm pretty biased because I
like getting paid but but IBM has been
one of the top contributors to PI spark
for spark 20 and I think this is really
cool given where we were coming from
about a year ago of not having a lot of
sort of depth in the Pythons park
community so that's awesome if you have
like a bunch of money and decide who to
buy support contracts from come talk to
an IBM sales person I don't know who
they are but I'm sure they're wonderful
people and they'll be very happy to see
you ok so so back to more serious
business we're going to look at sort of
how pie spark works because it's kind of
weird like this playground so spark
itself is written in Scala and therefore
has to run on the JVM and to make pie
spark work we use a mixture of pie for J
which is this really interesting
mechanism of calling java from python
and calling python from java using
sockets and that works surprisingly
that's pretty cool we also use a lot of
pickling and magic and it turns out that
both pickling and magic can be kind of
slow and this this can be the cause of a
lot of performance problems in spark
specifically pi spark so a lot of work
that we do is going to be to try and
avoid sort of some of these pickling
quite cases sparks equal really is the
place where we can go to avoid some of
this so sparks equal works by keeping
the data in the JVM for a really long
time and performing a lot of our actual
operations in the JVM as opposed to
perform in women Python so in dammit I
keep wanting to walk away from this Mike
sorry bad habits um so in general this
this looks like on our driver program
and we can think of this this is just a
program which you're running your your
shell in we have a python process and
it's talking to the JVM over a PI forge
a bridge and on our workers we have the
have a process talking to some Python
workers over a pipe and the Java process
is going to be the thing that's going to
go out to HDFS and fetch data parse
parque do all of those fun things for us
what our Python process is going to be
the thing which runs our actual like
Python code and and so this is this is
the general architecture it also
demonstrates that I do not have a
designer working with me as you can see
so yeah the double serialization cost is
something that I'm going to keep talking
about because it really hurts me Python
workers startup takes a bit of more time
than a regular worker does in in spark
land and there's some tricks that it
tries to do to reuse it but it doesn't
always work so sometimes your jobs will
be a little bit slower just because
there's this overhead of restarting
Python which isn't great really the
biggest problem that I've had with pi
spark is that the error messages make no
sense like just none as anyone like used
pie spark and gotten error messages from
it cool keep your hands up with those
error messages made sense oh ok so for
the recording the person said that's why
they found the Jupiter hide error
messages plug-in that just makes me
really sad as a PI spark developer but I
totally respect it 100% it's on us so
the error messages make no sense and
debugging is going to be painful it's
not just you the software is hard I'm
sorry Katie okay cool so um this
wouldn't be a big data talk especially
not a like intro intermediate Big Data
talk if I didn't have word count in it
they would take away my Big Data license
and I really like working with big data
so we have to look at word count I'm
sorry um but yeah so let's let's look at
sort of what's going on in this word
count are our first line assumes that we
have some data loaded into an RDD of
some type so this could have been loaded
from a text file it could have been
loaded from barkay I don't really care
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to flat map it so we're going to
take
and we're going to tokenize it using
spaces which definitely works for all
languages one hundred percent of the
time NLT k people are crazy then we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
construct this word count pair and we're
just going to use one for each of the
words at the start and then we just go
okay spark can you like take all of the
words that are the same and put them
together into like one big record and
this is this is really important because
our flat map and our map have been
happening on all of the worker machines
and each worker machine will have like
some of the data but it won't
necessarily have the data about the
words unless the input was already
pre-sorted in some way right like so it
won't have all of the data about the
same word so we need to do a shuffle and
that's where we sort of take the keys
and we hash them and then we send them
to different machines and we're happy
and then I go okay cool I'm gonna save
this out to a file and spark goes okay
I'll save this out to a file for you I'm
a happy person so that's awesome and I'm
like well I'm actually parsing log data
so in addition to seeing like the
different word counts I want to see how
many warning messages or errors yeah
warning messages there are in my data so
I have the second task and it's pretty
simple there's also it's just a filter
and filter on our DD behaves very
similar to like a filter on a normal
Python collection and so we just give it
this lambda expression and let lambda
expression gets sent off onto the work
thurs for us and it runs this and it
gives us back account and I can just
like print this count it's a normal
number but there's a problem here the
rtd reuse isn't magic so we did two
separate pieces of work on the same
input data and because we didn't tell
spark we were going to do that it's
actually had to load our input data
twice and the previous part about the
fastest data to process is the data I
don't have to load not the fastest data
to process as the data I load twice
that's very sad data so we need to tell
spark when we're using data multiple
times and this is this is kind of
confusing because you don't have to do
that when you're writing your code
locally right like you can iterate over
the same thing like six times save it
out five times you're fine you don't
have to tell Python anything that's good
but spark is actually you know going to
try
clean up once it's done doing its job
and so we need to tell spark no no
please hang on to this for me this is
important and it's okay because we can
just let be like hey hang on to this in
memory or if are things like really
really big we can ask spark to hang on
to it in memory and if it starts to run
out of space to just like stored those
are the discs for us and it'll be fine
there's also checkpointing I'm not going
to talk about it if you are running a
production cluster actually is anyone
running on a shared cluster environment
where their jobs frequently get
preempted okay you and I will chat
afterwards we'll skip before everyone
else it's great um there's some hacks we
can do but yeah so we need to tell spark
we want to use this data on multiple
times we just do that by calling cash or
persist on the rtd and spark keeps it
around for us it uses an LRU cache and
if we ask mark to catch a whole bunch of
stuff it's okay it'll just evict the
earlier things for us we don't have to
worry about like caching too much stuff
and making spark fail it just works the
other problem that we might have with
our data is if we have t skew right so
in our word count example probably not
going to have key skew because there's a
whole bunch of different words but we
might write like we might have a lot of
the instance of the keyword warning if I
was processing the log files for my own
software because there's a lot of
warrants that stuff's not well written
or if we have like sales data by zip
code right we're almost certainly going
to have a whole bunch of records that
all have the same key right and this can
be problematic for spark let's let's
look at how this can be problematic for
spark our ok let's look how this can be
problematic when we is grouped by Q and
spark so group like he is really evil
and I say this because group by key
sounds safe does group by key sound safe
to everyone okay most people seem to
think yeah um but it's not that makes it
evil like this cat it groups all of the
records with the same key together into
another record and this is this is
actually kind of sad because one of the
really nice things about spark is this
lazy evaluation and normally what that
means is that spark is able to have this
graph and optimize this graph of what
we've asked it to do
but there's a catch it isn't able to
peer inside of our lambda expressions so
when we've done our group by key and
then afterwards we sum the values spark
isn't able to know that what we're doing
is summing the values all it knows is we
have some lambda expression it can't
tell what we actually want to do and
yeah so even if we immediately some or
perform some type of reduction on it we
could create a record that's too big to
fit on a single one of our executives
yeah then our job fails and I'm sad you
get an error message which doesn't make
any sense because spark unless we're in
sequel and then everything just works so
if you're using data frames don't worry
but we can look at how this how this
explodes just like this this kind of
pissed off cat so here we've got
handlebar mustache data from the San
Francisco region as well as New York and
some other places and we can see that
the mission district which is 941 10 has
too many handlebar mustaches to be
stored on a single machine and so when
we do our group by key our record is
really really big and the other machines
also don't have a lot of data on them
right they each only have one piece of
data and so this is clearly not a good
use of our cluster resources I won't be
able to figure out where to start my
artisanal donut coffee who knows fish
shop right like I I won't know how to
sell mustache wax in San Francisco and
that's sad right because I really want
to retire soon this software thing is
too much work um but it's okay we can we
can do our computation and we can be
safe instead of using group by key we
can use one of the other primitives that
spark gives us and we can figure out
where to start our handlebar moustache
wax store so we load our data in same as
before we tokin eyes it same as before
but the thing here is we do reduce by
key instead of group by key and what
that does is it tells spark hey what's
up I I want you to take all of the
things with the same key and I want you
to take this lambda expression I want
you to apply it to their values together
I just want you to reduce them all up
kind of like a tree right and we're just
going to some these all together I'm
going to find out like the word count or
the number of handlebar mustaches in
each zip code and that's that's going to
be really useful and then we save it as
a file and that's the thing which
actually forces sparked to do this work
right in smart power lines the things in
this somewhat Gotti pinkish purple are
called transformations and and the thing
in red is an action and so
transformations don't normally cause
spark to do work and actions are the
part that spark to do work and we can
see oh okay I can see and I will read to
you that the the shuffle read for doing
a group like how damn it the shuffled
read for doing ooh ooh buttons yeah oh
okay the shuffled read for doing a group
by key is 40 8 kilobytes definitely
genuine big data I did this test on my
laptop but the same thing happens if we
do reduce by key except are shuffled
read is only 11 kilobytes and so we can
see that we've actually the amount of
data we're having to read as much
smaller when we switch from group by key
to reduce by key and sort of why is that
we get a free map side reduction and
this is really awesome for people coming
from Hadoop essentially spark goes hey
what's up you gave me this lambda
expression I'm going to apply it locally
on each of my workers for for all of the
keys that are the same and then I'll do
my network transfer and then I'll
reapply it after I've done my shuffle
and this means our shuffle is much
smaller and this is really important
because shuffles are kind of slow
relatively speaking right so if we can
reduce the data locally on each computer
first and then transfer it we get better
performance oh you're right and so
reduced by key doesn't work for like all
kinds of expressions sometimes you want
to do weird things with types and then
aggregate by key is your friend but
we're not going to look at that too much
but we can make spark fail in other ways
too yay um we can we can make spark fail
if we just ask it to sort our handlebar
mustache data and that's going to be sad
because like I want to start sending
these people selected targeted
advertisement
based on their zip code and so I need to
sort my list right and and so this is
what it looks like when we do our
shuffle explosion and we can see here
red red means bad and we don't get to
send our handlebar moustache ads so what
can we do to sort of deal with this
problem right so what we do is we
introduce some sort of little extra bit
of data that we don't actually care
about to the end of our key to allow
spark to sort of separate our handlebar
moustache data onto multiple machines
and this is kind of a hack sorry but
this hack exists because what we want to
do is allow sparks range partitioner to
construct distinct ranges for each
computer it can't have overlapping
ranges for computers so we have to
introduce something so it can split
between these machines and we will just
probably right afterwards we can just do
a map right afterwards to throw away the
part of the key we don't care about
right after we've done our shuffle and
everything will be ok but and we'll have
our sordid handlebar mustache day that
will work really well once again like if
you do this in production with PI spark
you get an error message that makes no
sense so it's great but you can look at
the web UI and you can see like all of
my data is going to one partition that's
probably a sign that one of these types
of things is happening and you can look
at your code and try and figure out what
it is and there's a wee bit of magic
hidden in the shuffle and we're gonna
skip it um but up next our Savior from
serialization data frames everyone loves
data frames right oh ok yeah ok yay boo
likes data frames um so data frames and
spark are especially important because
they let us keep data in the JVM right
not only do they give us this nice
structure that we can conceptually think
about but our data doesn't have to be
copied to Python nearly as often it's
pretty awesome but there's like kind of
a catch if you're coming from pandas or
our data frames your expectations are
probably
me I can't reach that high you probably
got pretty good expectations for what
data frames should be able to do and
spark data frames you're gonna you're
gonna start going down and yeah okay
cool so we're about here so spark tater
frames totally work right and that's
important but it's really important that
you don't just like try and take your
pandas code and be like why isn't this
working in spark I want magic why isn't
my magic happening and that's because
sport data frames implement the subset
of things that make sense in a
distributed context efficiently and so
there's a lot of things well not all of
it it's true um they classy um anyways
yeah and so there's a lot of things
which you can do in pandas which are
really difficult to do in a distributed
context and for that spark is just like
no that's cool you do that that's on you
and so for a lot of things which you
might be used to doing in pandas you
just like won't find what you're looking
for and you'll have to do some work on
your own it's kind of sad but it's okay
um well right and the other main the
other really important thing is to get
the most out of data frames instead of
writing our really happy lambda
expressions for the most part we want to
try and write sort of spark data frame
expressions and so instead of saying
lambda X X dot happy equals true oh I
didn't can look at whatever we're going
to do a filter and we're going to say
the DF column equals true and so we're
not giving it an arbitrary lambda
expression we're giving it this thing in
this sort of domain-specific language
for working with data frames and then
spark is able to peek inside the first
one and know what we're asking it to do
and it can actually push this operation
down to the data store if the data store
supports it and just only load the happy
pandas and we don't have to care about
this headband as ever it's great um so
why are data frames good for performance
they keep the stuff in the JVM they have
a more efficient in-memory
representation than pickled bites yeah
it's not that hard to have a more
efficient representation than just like
pickled strings but that they actually
have a really good one and this columnar
so if we only need to work on certain
parts of it we got some really nice
performance characteristics and yeah
it's even able to perform some
operations directly on the serialized
data and this is kind of cool so if
you're doing a sort it doesn't have to
deserialize Andrey serialize it provided
that you have like one of the supported
key types it just automatically does the
sort on the serialized data because the
comparator is implemented properly how
much faster can it be so red red is bad
right as group by key we're never going
to do group by key okay and blue blue is
good blue is reduced by key but you know
even our good our DD code can be vastly
outperformed by our data frame code and
so we can see here that the orange yeah
orange line is always much lower than
the blue line and this is the number of
iterations run and so you can see if
you're doing a bunch of operations that
are all the same the JVM [ __ ] kicks in
and we get really awesome stuff
happening but even if we're just doing
one operation like across a giant set of
data the data frame operation still
outperforms the native rdd operation so
if you're new to spark and you're like
trying to figure out if you want to
write your code against our d DS or data
frames start with data frames and then
if you encounter a roadblock you can
switch to our d DS and then go back to
data frames when when you want right
here's now admittedly the syntax for
loading some data in data frames isn't
as nice as just calling SC text file but
here we just ask it to load some CSV
data for us it's really simple I'm cause
I relatedly anyone work with JSON data
ok keep your hands up if you know the
schema for your JSON data ok so for
those of you that lowered your hands you
should really check out sparks equal it
will do schema inference on your JSON
data for you and that is worth its
weight in gold
um there are so many times someone has
handed me some JSON data and I'm like so
what's the scheme and they're like no no
it's JSON I'm just like oh god it's
going to be a long week but then spark
sequel is actually able to like sample
our JSON records figure out what the
variance is between them and then like
resample it and like actually tell us
like hey here's the schema probably with
some confidence or we can be like yo
spark I really need to know the schema
for sure go and read all of the records
and it will and it will figure out what
the scheme of your JSON data is
sometimes I even use this on small data
just because that part is so very
convenient and so yeah there's a whole
bunch of formats that you can work with
most of the Hadoop formats but also
other random things like red shift and
[ __ ] and Cassandra touch base and
there's a whole bunch of community
packages that provide additional formats
that aren't available directly inside of
spark and here we have a different type
of cat this is what happened when I
searched for cat loading and it was too
good to not keep so we can have our data
what can we do with it well because this
is like an intro ish big data course
we're gonna do word count again it's
going to be super exciting we could do
other things too but we're gonna do word
count oh we could we could print the
schema both come on let's do word count
no no I want my word count there we go
so we're going to do word count um very
exciting stuff so we we load some data
and then we select just the text part of
our data and then we go ahead and we do
this flat map if you're already using
spark 20 you actually have to turn it
into an RDD to apply an arbitrary lambda
expression to it if you're in spark 16
you don't have to do that and so this
code is valid spark 16 code it just
implicitly turns into an RDD behind the
scenes for you and then we go ahead and
we take our word and instead of making a
tuple we make a row and spark sequel is
able to understand rose we could also
have used a tuple but then we couldn't
have given it these nice names so we
could have but spark doesn't
Stan named tuple super well but so we
we've got like this this nice thing so
we go ahead we turn it into the word and
the count number one we group it
together by word and then we do the sum
and you're probably like Holden you told
me never to use group by you're lying
you're a terrible person and the answer
is we can use group by and sparks equal
because it doesn't have this arbitrary
lambda expression it's actually able to
say oh I don't need to actually group my
records together what I actually want to
compute is the sum and we could do any
other type of aggregation here we could
compute a whole bunch of variance
statistics or whatever we want to do and
sparks equal would know how to sort of
compute that locally on each machine
then shuffle the required data and
finish the compute and then we get
really awesome performance yay but this
this isn't as awesome as it could be
right that that flat map part is still
going to be comparatively slow to
someone writing in Scala but that's okay
we can mix Python and Java code together
for a sort of weird looking Frankenstein
that runs very quickly data frames are
really the best example of how to do
this you can do stuff with our TVs in
the JVM it's just going to be really
hard because you have to parse pickled
bytes in the JVM and there's not like a
lot of good tools for doing that so I'm
going to focus on how to do this with
data frames so you can go and get your
Scala or Java developer and be like I
need this function it needs to go really
fast I'm running it on a lot of data
please make this function for me and
then after you buy them a cup of coffee
or however you bribe people in your
organization to do work for you they
they write this little function for you
and you can now call it from Python and
it's going to be pretty awesome and the
catch is it's going to be pretty awesome
but we're going to use a whole bunch of
internals to do it and using internals
kids we can go real fast well I get
probably not going to work tomorrow
you'll have to update your code when you
update
spark and I'm sorry I wish these things
weren't internals but I totally
understand why they are there they're
very much implementation details so
let's look at using that so here we go
ahead and our spark context actually has
a pointer to the JVM so we can go ahead
and we can say hey I want to register my
udfs that my my java friend gave me and
we can just like ask spark to register
these udfs for us and everything will be
awesome and happy and we can start using
those JVM udfs from python directly if
anyone's working with over a billion
columns the schema is serialized as json
from the JVM to python and you're going
to have a bad time if you try and access
the schema information so don't do that
yeah there's this really handy function
on spark data frames called two pandas
and what it does is it takes a
distributed data frame and it converts
it into a local pandas dataframe and
obviously we can only do this once we've
filtered our data down enough for subset
it in some way but it's important to
remember like this is essentially
calling collect and in spark calling
collect is kind of slow because it
brings all the data back to a single
node and that's not really fast right
it's much faster to save it out to a
distributed system than bringing it back
to a single node another cool thing that
we can do with data frames is we can
join them together and inadvertently if
we join a data frame with itself and we
have a lot of key skew we can
accidentally do the cross product and as
i like to say the cross product of big
data and big data is an outofmemory
exception so be careful with your joins
especially self drawings because there's
a chance they could explode so so look
at your key distribution whoo fancy ad
style graphics um PR number one three
five seven one is unfortunately probably
not going to get merged but it makes
things go really fast and so I'm going
to talk about it because I think it's
cool actually I'm just going to
to show you this graph because it's a
really cool graph and we can see here
that the the Python performance gets
really close to the native scallop
performance for the simple UDF and it's
really awesome and if you want to review
it if any of you are like really excited
about reviewing code in an open source
project which is having a debate over
how it wants to manage its governance
currently you can go and check out this
pull request it'll be lots of fun and
and you can give me feedback like
seriously I really want to hear from
people outside of the normal spark
developer community what they think of
this somewhat questionable idea or what
other things we should be trying instead
I'd love to hear from you all there's a
future we might integrate a bunch of
things we might make it so that you can
take your spark data frame and use desk
on top of it and that would be really
awesome and you could do like really
cool things potentially we could also do
really fast interchange between Python
and spark and that could be kind of cool
i really want anyone that has udfs that
they're willing to share with me please
share them with me so I can use them for
my evil plan to benchmark and trick
people into merging my code yeah a bunch
of resources really the important one is
you want to buy several copies of my
book and you also probably don't want to
buy that book which i wrote too but it's
really out of date fast data processing
with spark is really out of date please
don't buy it it's like spark road 7
we're on spark 20 but please buy my new
book especially if of a corporate
expense account it is the gift of the
season i recommend six per person in
your organization more seriously it's
it's only half done but you can give me
your money today so please do spike
videos if this is your first
introduction to spark and you're like
wow lady up there is talking really fast
and I don't know what's going on Paco
has no amazing introduction in the spark
video it's on YouTube it's free i highly
recommend it
if you have a corporate expense account
he has like a really professional one
done with O'Reilly so you can give paw
calm IM pop was a really good person so
please use the corporate expense account
for good and there's there some other
spark videos too so that's pretty much
it I think I'm out of time I suspect but
I'll be hanging I mean I can take
questions until the other person shows
up to kick me out you have a question
yay ha yeah no no no so the initial data
frame API wasn't available from Python
but it since become available in Python
and you can do really awesome things
with it and I think there are people
here for the next talk hanging outside
so I should probably let go but if you
have questions I'll be hanging out in
the hall to answer them thank you so
much for coming